oh
c'est un mal cruel il s'en prend aux
plus faibles aux plus âgés aux plus
pauvres de la société mais aussi aux
minorités sur les civières aux soins
intensifs
beaucoup d'afro américains victimes du
coronavirus dans les morgues aussi un
mois et demi après le début de
l'épidémie aux etats-unis les chiffres
commencent à être publiés et font froid
dans le dos ryland on vit fred spry les
noirs représentent 30% de la population
mais totalise 55 % des décès s'est mis
en oeuvre depuis une dizaine d'années
fred un barbier sensibilisé clients et
les gens de sa communauté aux problèmes
de santé et leur dispense des conseils
d'hygiène et de prévention
mais l'épidémie coronavirus la force et
a fermé son salon de coiffure
c'est donc aujourd'hui sur les médias
sociaux qu'il partage des vidéos sur le
lavage des mains et l'importance de
rester chez soi un message qui a pris
trop temps selon lui à se propager dans
la communauté afro américaine
la conséquence se comptent en milliers
de vies à milwaukee
soixante-dix pour cent des morts sont
afro américains alors qu'ils ne
représentent que 26 % de la population
chicago et la louisiane vivent des
situations similaires
une disproportion qui s'explique en
bonne partie par des problèmes de santé
très répandue au sein de la communauté
noire comme le diabète et des maladies
cardio respiratoire c'est du moins ce
qu'avance le médecin chef américain john
adams avoue au passage qu'il a lui-même
tous ces problèmes
pour le docteur steven turner il est
inadmissible dans ces conditions qu'il
n'y ait toujours pas de statistiques
nationales détaillées sur les victimes
de lakovic 19 au style flamboyant nous
avons sont toujours à l'aveuglette
déplore-t-il et les minorités sont
invisibles and hate arbres selon lui la
prévalence de la maladie au sein des
minorités s'explique aussi en grande
partie par la pauvreté mais les faux
frais les gens évitent souvent d'elle à
l'hôpital dit il parce qu'ils ont peur
de ne pas pouvoir payer la facture
decker mais pour fred le barbier
c'est aussi une question de culture dans
notre communauté dit il les gens aiment
être ensemble dans les bons moments
comme quand ça va mal mais maintenant
que la peur s'installe les habitudes
pense-t-il vont peut être changer aux
etats unis la santé est sans doute la
plus grande des inégalités d'espérance
de vie des afro-américains et déjà de
quatre rangs inférieure à la moyenne
nationale et le coronavirus ne va rien
arranger
et si jean françois bélanger radio
canada mary 2